hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
some shocks is a legendary banana hold
to happy in st. Eagle ace we're counting
down the top 10 PS oasis of all time
coming in at number ten is olofmeister
disgusting tech 9 8 at ESL one Katowice
2015 really cool
these will find that kill us watching
you is going to look up behind and now
they know definitely now we have the
information at this point in time it's
going to be Guardian to Kiev grim and
serious look at that running and gutting
take down JW and all of my spine and
armor it's a really really good
combination but on that they fight for
one of the time oh my god they will
pronax helping out with that killing
dhania going down and sound with triple
kill for love my she's got plenty of
help to do this as well
juice is very low please although oh my
god he gets another Killian now trots
running out seven seconds all of Mike
looking for the kill 5 seconds it goes
go ahead Scott and it's going to be the
round gun and fnatic feel it all of
Meister feels it at number 9 is the
Polish legend himself Neil with an
insane one d5 question against team dig
at Dreamhack we dread
what are we witnessing now Neil the last
one left you know one on four Dignitas
assigning it is not over yet they want
to fight and they want to continue to
battle neo very nearly lost the second
one will through the wall and now with
this smoke he can get the bomb planted
the problem is signet sounds have a lot
of grenades throughout their disposal
kevlar nak they have two smokes left and
i have really become video because he
has a molotov and I bet he would love to
use the device time but they've already
smoked down the form there's another
headshot coming through he have to go
over the 8th touch into winning the
semi-final ta looking for another spray
Neil gonna get a go from on yeah
Hey drops right into the grand final
number eight on the list is Pitts no
armor aides and one before clutch from
the EC se215 that's the thing has paid
off for the getting seconds amber to get
it hit the loss last and again jumping
p20 chronically must be done
if you can guess I killed at the
father's what a nice office engineer
Oh
coming in at number seven is rain with
an unbelievable 1v5 clutch against key
menus at Dreamhack utopia is ruthless
sneaking down three players now it's
just rain left alive he's going to find
a quick kill on happy but it's got Co
schemers we're kids name with what a
frag they're coming in from rain you can
be pushing it to the bottom side the pop
is on his back you've got the smoke per
cover we can't make the approach to the
bombs plane you tell to have some
climbers way-o try to get the flag onto
the flanking player the games from this
man is unreal there's still few more
players to find those Grady's going to
get another one fpk goes out he's
created a 101 he's got so much time to
use as well he's going to make his way
back back towards the middle position
I'm gonna try it's Rick opponent right
now apex oh all right goodness gracious
me rain is an absolute monster that is
why the bond with it requires a lot of a
confounder at number 6 is Kenny asses
impenetrable D sight defense against n
IP from Tebow 17 yeah
Bush has been fighting has been cold and
found out Kenny I wanna see game was
what he's looking directly for anything
whatever you can do I can do better
precise for all our fighting my mind has
been blown up and then he'd come to hold
me right other than amazing number 5 is
he feels absolutely amazing deagle a
from the second season of the ESL esea
pretty well mouses by is going to be
torn away from the very very quickly my
time oh my god oh I don't believe it
shocked them has justify one more the
money isn't going to touch him and what
on earth has just happened eagle is on
fire chakra can I walk into as well nico
is on fire v he recovers the AEK as well
and mouths get pulled kicking and
screaming into their ninth round at
number four is this godly B side hold by
shock from 2014 fragbite masters
going to flash their way through the
smoke and now it's gonna come down to
sake he's going to get caught in the
corner though get them running shot I do
get the second what song he's making it
happen aside what shocks me so far
shocks me as a god the eighth coming in
at number three is this mind blown by JW
from 2014
Dreamhack Stockholm International
Limited on money whatever and there you
go JW once again picks up the kill on
Kenny s comparison it really seems like
the ski off is the most powerful weapon
here I summon infernal enters changes so
why the way but some got the Ebola
rocket through the smoke they have a
second member hit the bump side of this
holiday rotation happening fences are
actually a horrible sport right now - -
state school they're going to be fine
106 but I always saw getting so will
unique gets a second one he's looking
for the AC God's just seven bullets and
he's gonna go for it in the corner now
so one-on-one image if I shot this 25
seconds left any sub six health and he's
got over the scene said phrase here this
is stuff to the corner now
once he second we're kidding
number two is he goes inhuman one be
five clutch against sponsor live from
people's ages even equipped was only the
tech 9 and trapped in Claude Pico would
show the world exactly why he's known
for his ability to pull through in the
classic from the seaside a well once
again just being eco developer
Louisville yeah with all we've got three
from behind quad can he find the forest
he gets the parsley he's odd for the
image
[Music]
I feel like I'm trapped I'm trapped
inside of the moon right now in a human
reaction either what I need I need a
tactical timeout for the caching death
Oh
ah who's ready to pause what finally the
number one play on the list is none
other than happy to storage Eagle ace
from dreamhack open london sweet time
hoping to catch somebody peak on envious
side and well that's what happens when
you go around the corner happy with
wanting Oh get it a little here - debris
debris is like sweating bullets passes
that I guess
still holding up against the test of
time
Happy's Eagle ace is still and will most
likely continue to be to stick as asian
csgo history so there you have it you
feel like we missed something on our
list let us know in the comments below
if you want more great content be sure
to hit that subscribe button
[Music]